so crazy patients and hustlers like
these are I love that you're just like
the scope of what you could possibly do
like acting like a stripper you're like
all these things so did you study for
that like do you have to because I know
that a lot of actors like really get
into the roles and want to know and be
able to portray the character properly
did you do that for all of them
oh yeah fresh off the boat I had three
boys just oh I got all these babies no
not really what I did I didn't work at a
strip club to get ready for hustlers you
did I wonder what it you have to do
did you strip I gave lap dances a
strange your fear lies I'm not mine
you're not lying
you're not lying I mean 600 bucks my
[Applause]
fake tattoos on my neck and I like
change my hair like I put like a you
know you could be like another person
that's awesome yet or you who knows you
really went like for it and that's
probably why you pull it off so well in
the theater like in the movie oh well I
mean I think a big part of I guess
pulling it off is is having a great team
around you and I think working with
Jennifer and the girls yeah I mean we
really loved each other yeah and she's
really kind of she's the best and so I
think that's really what made the movie
for me I mean the stripping helped me to
know that feeling you know you can't
duplicate it the first time you walk
into a club and say hey I would like to
have a job here and then you go work
that night oh my god yeah did you do the
pole thing cuz I actually tried doing it
once there was okay not weirdos my
family but there is like what it was
like we were all it like if some I don't
even know where it was I motel room in
Vegas we all went for like news even
there happened to be a pole in the
middle remember like what freaky things
have happened in this room
we all try and I will broke everything
like it turns out it's really super
athletic and hard it is really hard
my install do you think you can do
anything
oh right yeah and when you're naked they
don't get out here that good depends on
the kind of neck hey that's another
thing you learned but ice installed a
stripper pole in my living room a few
months wait are you are you with someone
because they're excited if you my
husband would be like yeah I will not
stop talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this